and like let them
cry and they're shaking and somebody you
know this they keep telling them not to
cry Rashida T congresswoman from
Michigan who is from Dearborn Michigan
which basic I mean they held I think I
have no problem saying in essence it was
a modern-day Nazi rally last week I mean
it was absolutely insane no one is
making the distinction there was not one
person there who made the distinction
between the Palestinian flag and the
actions of Hamas not one person I mean
can you imagine one guy raising his hand
and being like guys actually Hamas went
a little too far they they would love to
take him out too anyway here she is
yesterday uh inciting the Insurrection
and also lying about the uh the bombing
of the hospital which we'll get to in a
moment continue to watch people think
it's okay to bomb a
hospital we're
children you know what's so hard
sometimes who's watching those videos
and and the people telling the kids
don't cry and like let them
cry and they're shaking and somebody you
know this they keep telling them not to
cry in
Arabic they do they can cry I can cry we
all can cry if we're not crying
something is wrong and so I'm telling
you right
now President Biden not all America's
with you on this one and you need to
wake up and understand that we are
literally watching people commit
genocide Ben uh did she pump out any of
those crocodile tears for the babies
that were burned or the women that were
raped or the Holocaust Survivors that
are now kidnapped or the I don't know
say 20 plus American hostages I could go
on by the way she she doesn't even pump
out those tears for Palestinian
civilians who are killed the reason that
you know this is because she's still
telling the lie that Israel bombed the
hospital so for example it's kind of an
an an obvious point but one that that is
pretty amazing when you think about it
so for a hot second Kamas puts out
propaganda that Israel has bombed a
hospital killing 500 people in the Gaza
Strip and that is implausible from the
start if it were to be a deliberate
bombing specifically because Israel for
example has not blown up the alifa
hospital which everyone knows literally
everyone knows sits on top of the Kamas
military headquarters and has for a
decade everyone knows this alifa is
still standing because Israel does not
wish to kill hundreds of civilians
Israel is doing its utmost I mean really
set most not to kill civilians the truth
is that if Israel were doing everything
it militarily had to do right now
there'd be a lot more civilians dead not
just because they'd be bombing buildings
but because the tunnels are where the
Hamas Fighters are hiding and they are
all hiding under civilian areas Israel
knows this they're not using their heavy
ordinance on those tunnels specifically
because Hamas is shielding those tunnels
with civilians in any case well just
real wait wait just pause for one second
because the truth I think it's a point
worth reiterating because the truth is
they could end this in in 3 days
basically if they wanted if they wanted
to do the unimaginable to defend their
citizens they could have this basically
in 3 days if they wanted to do all of
the things that you're making Point
superiority they have the ammunitions to
do it if Israel wanted to destroy every
single tunnel not even knowing where
they're mapped if they wanted to destroy
all this tunnel and bury the Kamas
terrorists under Rubble they could do
that it would take an awful lot of
Civilian casualties which is why they're
not doing it and also why Hamas is
hiding civilians at top their tunnels
that's literally the reason Hamas is by
by its own behaviors admitting that
Israel seeks to avoid civilian
casualties that's that's why they put
the civilians there if they if they
thought that Israel was just out to kill
civilians it wouldn't matter where the
civilians are they'd be trying to save
their own civilians by separating the
military fighters from the civilians
they're doing the opposite so the the
the news goes out that that Israel has
supposedly done an air strike on on a
hospital and 500 are dead it goes out in
like five minutes they've got the dead
counted never mind that Israel is still
two weeks later trying to figure out
precisely how many people are dead in
the October 7th
massacres Kamas knew within five minutes
the entire world media pumps this out
they they all pump it out and it's all
atrocities look what Israel did and then
it turns out the New York Times runs a
full front page photo of the wrong
building of a different building
suggesting that that was the hospital
that was blown up and then it turns out
that it was a Palestinian Islamic Jihad
rocket that fell short because like 10%
of the rockets that are fired fall into
Gaza because they don't give it any
bleeps about their own citizens
obviously and um and it hit a it didn't
hit the hospital it hit a parking lot
next to the hospital and the actual
number of dead is probably not 500 is
probably we're now finding out maybe 10
to 50 uh it doesn't matter the the the
entire world goes insane I mean
congrations everywhere things on fire
giant protest and TB out there oh my God
the babies oh my God the babies when it
comes out as it already has that it was
a Palestinian Islamic Jihad rocket that
hit a that that even if it had hit a
hospital and killed 500 people her move
would then not be why is Palestinian
Islamic Jihad firing rockets that kill
civilians in Gaza it would be this never
happened it would be this is not
important anymore I'm not going to talk
about this right it exits the front page
the minute right that it can't be blamed
on the Jews it exits the front page
that's how you know all this is
crocodile
tear